the Christmas agenda is set I'm Brent
Goff in Berlin it's time to talk a
Bangladesh garment factory disaster that
shocked the world eight months on what
has changed the Christmas tradition as
we know it today made not in Bethlehem
but in Germany and helping a worthy
cause is just a click away so why the
guilty conscience welcome to this
Christmas edition of agenda everyone I
have invited three people today to talk
argue and pry apart these headlines one
of the best gifts you can give this
Christmas is your online voice of
support that is the holiday tip coming
from Paula
Hahnemann she is the Germany head of
change.org it claims to be the world's
biggest online petition platform we're
looking forward to unwrapping that gift
Paula good to have you on the show well
he loves the German Christmas originals
such as a decorated tree and lots of
lights but the american-born Berlin
local satirist Eric Hanson says a little
more commercialism here would increase
the Yuletide glow you're gonna have
you're gonna have a tough sell on that
one Eric good to have you on the show
well the retail orgy before Christmas
would not be possible as we know it
without the ridiculously cheap labor of
thousands of people in Bangladesh's
garment industry and that brings me back
to a non machine he is a Bangladeshi
British film maker and not it's good to
have you back on the show I'm you were
here last spring after that garment
factory collapsed in Dhaka I think more
than a thousand people were killed you
were on a mission back then to document
the plight of people who make basically
the shirts on our backs
what did you find out oh thank you for
having me back first lots of things have
happened since since I was last on the
show one of the main things that's
happened just recently has been the rage
in there though
the rise in the minimum wage to 5000
taka so that's like 73 euros I think so
what what they really wanted was 8,000
tacos which is a hundred around $100
story that was 73 dollars is that a
living wage in me can we move on there
well not ready to be honest but the
problem was that you know they the
government could not decide them the
8,000 tacos because they actually
thought the buyers that are you know
companies like your H&M your a Primark
and these guys they thought that they
would not agree to that
so they second-guessed them and this and
they said let's go for five thousand
tacos now that's that's a shame it's a
victory in a sense because the wage
before was three thousand Tucker's and
now it's five thousand swear they've got
you know this an extra two thousand
three hundred five thousand three
hundred actually is in total so they've
got a bit more there to play with but
still I don't think it's enough I think
it should be they should they should go
to a thousand because that's what the
garment workers won they feel that
sufficient to live off you know that's
sufficient to be able to pay for their
rent to be able to save some money to
pay for their bills keep in mind all of
these workers are providing monies for
their families who live in the villages
they're providing for their siblings to
be able to get an education and you know
on on what was 3,000 Tucker's before
that's not possible even on 5,000
Tucker's it might be possible but it
still means those workers are still the
conditions that they're living in is not
great I mean they're not living in good
conditions they're not making a lot of
money and yet they're supporting
families with this and they're doing all
of that just so we can go and buy cheap
t-shirts and you know shirts at
Christmastime like we've done this year
is it in your mind's when you go out and
do your shopping do you think about I
mean the people basically who have
suffered so that we can have presents
well I think one of the biggest
achievements of those campaigns and with
all the NGOs and organizations and the
workers on the ground hood fighting for
more rights more labor rights has been
done that if now a Western consumer I
know that from myself I know this from a
lot of friends I have if they look at
the tag and see made in Cambodia or made
in Bangladesh they actually have not a
blank thought in their mind
but they know exactly what this means
this means cheap labor bad labor
conditions if I and they still buy but
I'm just saying you know if it needs
time in the brain to completely from a
thought to your action to change it but
it's already there the news is out there
and people know by knowing there's it
made much of a difference that they
still buy but what would you say here I
think it's kind of a an illusion that
were that we're changing our our
attitudes and that we're becoming more
aware of anything I think we're it's a
it's a it's the kind of thing this
awareness is the kind of things we talk
about we're drinking coffee or drinking
beer but when we're actually buying
something it's really not important
especially for like maybe 95 percent of
the of the population the normal guy out
there just wants a cheap shirt and I'm
not sure that he's really wrong I'm not
sure that is his responsibility what's
going on Bangla exactly I mean let's you
know let's bring some common sense to
the consumer why should the consumer
have to think about such things when
they're going to buy something as simple
as a t-shirt they can pressure companies
and that is if a company is a consumer
brand and brands that's a working for
the biggest campaigning platform I can
tell you that companies want to protect
their brands because that's the most
important s that they have the most
value of units that they have and as
soon as the information is out there
that there's brands of using labor
rights there's so much more target
points you can tackle in campaigns and
we see this happening every day on
change at org there's tons of campaigns
from consumers being started against
small retailers big retailers to start
asking to have a responsible production
chains and that's a first step I'm not
saying it's the whole solution I'm
saying it's there's so much more
awareness than there was eight or ten
years ago yeah I mean I'll grant you
that I mean just because of shows like
what we're doing right now people know
about it and that is a good thing
but these workers you know they have a
lot to deal with I mean it's not just
the walls and the roofs of Bangladesh's
garment factories that can be deadly
the latest killer fires nearly 800
people have been injured in dozens of
workplace fires most of these go
unreported and international labor
advocacy groups say it is disturbing
proof of the slow pace of change
last April the Rana Plaza building on
the outskirts of the Bangladeshi capital
Dhaka collapsed burying thousands of
garment industry workers under the
rubble a three week rescue operation
began in the end over 1,100 people lost
their lives it was the worst clothing
factory incident in history in a country
that regularly sees deadly industrial
accidents the collapse sparked mass
worker protests the big fashion chains
that purchased the mass-produced
clothing have been wary about accepting
responsibility and victims of the
disaster have so far received little
compensation several months after the
accident garment industry unions have
managed to wrangle a new monthly minimum
wage and to prepare a new Accord on
Factory safety which some major chains
including Walmart in the US have refused
to sign so has there been any real
progress on conditions in the garment
industry in Bangladesh or is everything
still just business as usual yeah do the
workers in Bangladesh do they now feel
that the world knows what they're
dealing with every day know that
definitely they do because of the
coverage the Rana Plaza disaster got you
know something we've not seen anything
as huge as that but it was strong what
you were saying about the fires you know
the fires there's one a week at the
moment it's gone so bad you know and 80%
of them of these fires are just like
electrical cuts you know it's very very
bad wiring and because of that you're
getting you're getting these huge fires
and now this is like this is a big
killer as well you know not only is that
a building collapse but just you know
you like you said yourself 800 people
have died and though the other big
problem with that is is that none of
these brands are actually owning up to
this they're not handing out the
compensation so like these people who
are getting injured and they're not able
to work after that they're not getting
any compensation Walmart's not giving
them compensation and right there are
certain either Walmart these big change
I mean they really have gotten an easy
ride in the last eight months I mean I
there really hasn't been a lot of bad
press for a Walmart despite the fact
that they refuse to sign any type of
binding into exactly their very bullish
I think they're very bullish in this how
they how they've been behaving with
since the Rana Plaza since the tazreen
fire as well and since the other little
fires that are happening you know
they're they they're not willing to
they're not willing to own up to that
but what's the leverage they've got
because what couldn't the government of
Bangladesh say you guys either sign on
or you can't do business here well this
is the thing you know and that's what I
think the Bangladeshi government's got
to be they they themselves reporters to
be a bit bullish as well because they've
got to realize that well hold on warm
are here for a reason because our
workers are able to make these garments
they make them very quick they're
efficient so they should they should
think well actually we don't want our
workers our workforce to be dying making
these clothes you know we've got to look
at this workforce and protect there's a
Walmart's there because these workers
are cheap and let's be honest about this
is it possible I mean you know the area
could Walmart pack up and say okay we're
going over to another country because
those people are even cheaper they'll
have the same problems though don't you
think that even if they went somewhere
else you know what's going where they're
gonna go you know Sri Lanka Afghanistan
where were they gonna go and it's just
gonna be taking up the same same types
of problem if it's that obvious then why
aren't the politicians in Bangladesh
using the leverage they have well I
think I think now because since the Rana
Plaza and since there's been so much
pressure on the Bangladeshi government
you start to see changes happening there
there are more health and safety checks
teams have been set up I was talking to
the leader of the national garment
workers Federation just before I came
here actually talked to give it to give
me an update on what's happening and he
was saying actually the government they
have started to do things one of the
other things that you can say that the
government also has also in which the
brands didn't do was it was they
actually they know with the compensation
they actually they start to hand out
compensation to the families but they
also get they also paid for the funeral
services they also paid for the injured
now the bronze huh to pay for the
funeral yeah but you know you know
something what you need to look at is is
that will hold on there people who are
the culprits in this the brands they've
not done that you know unlike away it
should be it should be the government
plus the brands do it doing this type of
thing not just them them I mean they
can't rely on the government to be an
advocate for them right and he's
protecting the workers besides people
like you its unions the unions are very
strong then one of the other things
that's happened since the Rana Plaza
it's become easier to form unions which
is a very positive step is that you know
these these workers can feel as though
they've got somewhere to go you know if
if they're no getting paid on time if
they feel as though they're in danger
they've got someone to understand that I
mean because you know here here in
Europe when you think about having
strong unions you're not gonna have
people working in any place where you've
got bad wiring where fires are starting
so yeah I mean you know how to square
that circle for me how can you have
strong unions and a dangerous work we're
still in this infancy as well remember
you know keep in mind in you know in
Europe and the Americas unions have been
around for a long time
unions in Bangladesh we only started in
something like the 80s 90s you know
and now unions are being formed just
recently because of the government has
made it easier so we can't expect
everything to just happen with a click
of a finger
yeah what about help from european
union's i mean are you seeing any of
that there is i I remember we went just
a few years ago and we had like a shop
steward from unison actually a big Union
in the UK who came with us those links
are there the ng WF you know this is one
of the unions that I work a lot with
they've been working with unions here
unions have been bringing bringing you
know their members over to come here to
talk to you know its members in the UK
so there is that connection and as
there's you know the it's the same with
Germany and Holland for example under
States so there are you know unions here
who are working with unions over there
to be able to what about political
pressure coming from Europe and the EU
is the rest there is yes there is
there's political pressure come from
coming from the states as well as
political pressure from London as well
at the UK so you know these things these
types of things are happening as well
but I think one of
main things is that it's time that the
bronze actually stood up and look how
look at what they're doing you know it's
good that I think through things like
change to org you are starting to see
that the you know you're all remember of
the public they want the bronze to know
that we know what's going on and we want
to say something even if it is just
press click and I'm gonna sign a
petition via that then let it just be
that orifice going outside gap and doing
a protest let it be that you know but I
think you know now there's a generation
here who who want the branch to know
that we know what's going on and it's
time that you guys start to look at the
way you're behaving because it's not
like we're in this 80s or something like
that are you know where they could do
whatever they want in places like
Cambodia or Thailand making drive me
there is my parents at the end of the
day people want a cheap t-shirt period
but I think there will be at one point
production train stop being looked over
I have a quick question do you think
like it took decades the last century in
the Western industrialization to improve
worker slides rights do you think the
connectivity of the world will kind of
speed up that process in countries where
industrialization is just starting I
mean if you compare this the same Pettus
right there we had exploitation in
Germany leapfrog yeah in development can
you see that because I'm not an expert
in addition but can you see that there's
a fast trick for those countries I start
I am starting to see a fast track at the
moment especially with for example we be
talking about the minimum wage now for
Bangladeshis or during Bangladeshi
government work because that's a big
deal that's a big issue they've been you
know not that long ago they closed 400
factories so that they could go out and
protest about this so it's a big issue
and when I was there in 2010 making a
documentary they were protesting then
and and the minimum wage did get risen
and prior to that they had to wait many
years so now it's only been three years
and it's been risen again and I can
imagine that is that's gonna continue to
rise because they they can see that
their workers are a point yep they can
put pressure on these brands on these
factories on the government to make
changes so economics to you is is on the
workers side I mean the latest numbers
that
that we've been reporting on is that by
the year 2020 it's not that long away
the average worker middle-class worker
in China will earn the same as the
middle-class worker in the United States
earns all right so they're going to be
parity there right well still I mean and
you know you've got China there's this
is this huge it's this huge power in
Asia with influence so it's going to be
harder for countries like Bangladesh to
tell their workers you know you have to
work for peanuts
so economics you could argue is on their
side but we're being really optimistic
here you know it's Christmas you know we
want the time to be optimistic here but
at the end of the day the responsibility
for the consumer I mean sometimes I feel
like there's a little bit of flower
children you know if I were child music
playing in our heads when we think that
when people go shopping for clothes that
they're really going to be thinking
about you know the plight of the
seamstress and not thinking about you
know the the width of their waist I mean
isn't that realistic well there is a
truth to that statement and I think it
probably there's a lightness that we I
mean human beings have that that kind of
how do you say take height like to
change directions but again I mean
what's the point of not being positive
to to try to change things yeah I think
but I think the problem is also with
almost this generation or even that the
start of this movement of trying to
change the the actions of companies
since the 70s it's kind of an illusion
it's kind of we're doing it for
ourselves the people who have changed
we've got the the the minimum wage in
Bangladesh with the people who went out
on the streets and sort of throwing
things at the government at their
politicians it's not some guy sitting at
home clicking on a link I think I think
we imagine that we're doing all this
wonderful things that were very aware of
politics and what's going on in the
world but in fact all we really want to
do is buy those those cheap clothes and
we're not really it's almost like a
hobby we're not really doing it right
but there's nothing wrong I mean to
there's nothing wrong with wanting to be
a carefree shopper no and something is
always better than nothing right I mean
you I mean it's all it's what you're
both doing is good but we're not live
this is not paradise and and the human
being is not gonna change from what it
was you know 20 years ago 100 years ago
five hundred years ago he's still a guy
who was looking out for his own good for
his own enjoyment it's he has his own
priority yeah
before we move on your work where does
it go from here well we've got a few
projects coming out me and Richard
you're quite direct films where they've
got a documentary coming out Colin must
say about you just saw a clip from it
that's about child labor actually and
Parv it is actually set in a garment
factory and that's why you saw those
clips and then we aim to do another
documentary on the Rana Plaza disaster
as well to give it to give people an
update and what's happening to look at
some of the families that have been
affected by it and to actually look at
the unions who are actually going out
there on the street trying to get
justice for those victims who have not
received anything yet because I think
better that's one of the biggest things
is that these young women who are
breadwinners of their families are not
breadwinners anymore and now other
members of their families younger
siblings are having to go out there and
work and now I think the brands really
need to be doing the right thing and I
think that's when people like change dog
do come in because from the if you're
based in Germany if you're based in the
UK US or whatever that's one of the
things that you can do I talk to the the
leader of the Union in Bangladesh and I
asked him what do you think you know
people in places like England and the
and you know Germany or wherever cuncun
do that's what he says you just need to
put some pressure on the brands no one's
saying boycott or anything like that but
do put some pressure let them know what
I think we're good and plus you know you
work obviously you know you're doing a
lot for the people in Bangladesh all
right from one troubling retail reality
to another have you heard of Black
Friday that is the name given to the day
after the Thanksgiving holiday in the
u.s. it has become a national event
stores open at midnight and offer big
sales to jump start the Christmas
holiday shopping season now the images
this year were disturbing masses of
people pushing their way to get into
stores trampling each other hitting
cursing sometimes stabbing well you
won't catch me near that craziness but I
do ask myself where is the connect
between the Christmas story of baby
Jesus and mobs of consumers shedding any
hint of intelligent life just to get a
bargain Christmas a time of lights here
in Northern Europe the holiday means
many different things to many different
people some see it as a time to stop and
ponder a time to help others a time to
give a time for family and loved ones
but there's another side of the holiday
as well as the big day approaches the
gift buying season begins Christmas is
very big for the retail business the
buying frenzy won't stop until December
26th and everywhere there are rituals
even Bethlehem has a tree nowadays
many Christmas customs have their roots
in Germany and the holiday is no longer
just for Christians so what's the real
message of modern Christmas that's a
great question for you to answer Eric um
I think we've forgotten or have
completely forgotten that Christmas is
it has two elements one is you know
celebrating the birth of Christ and
that's was originally on or was often
celebrated on the 24th but the other is
a saint day it's a birthday of Saint
Nicholas who was a real Saint in the I
think the fourth century of the fifth
century in what we now know as turkey
and he really went around he was a
bishop and he really went around giving
gifts to people if there was a young
girl from a poor family who could not
marry because he didn't have a dowry he
gave her gifts money usually and though
so that he could that girl could find a
husband and this this this celebration
of a giver of a selfless giving was
imported in I think the 10th century to
Germany and then from here it was
imported to other places right there so
the Germans took a Turkish man giving us
money to single women and turned it into
Christmas that's right this was before
it you know under today's laws he would
be in jail of course actly but but and
then and then under Luther Luther of
course banned st. days because it was a
Catholic holiday and so but because he
couldn't get rid of the the gift of the
tradition of giving he moved st.
Nicholas to Christmas he could bind
Christmas and st. Nicholas and that's
why we're selling now we're celebrating
now on the 24th - actually two things
that the birth of Christ or Christianity
and giving wit and I think and this all
this buying you got to remember when
people go out there go crazy buying
things they're buying things usually for
other people and I think that's even
though it's crazy and nuts and it's
overblown and too expensive it's still a
good thing in general we're still giving
something to someone else I think that's
good I mean I'll agree with you it's
good to give but I guess it's how you
give - right and what you give I don't
know I mean I you know I think I think
if
if I'm a guy and I need a you know I
need money to go to college you know and
someone someone gives me that money out
of ulterior motives because he wants to
you know everyone to know that he's a
great guy I still have the money and I
can still go to college I don't care
about his alternate motives I mean the
giving is still as a as a value in
itself is still there I don't like the
guy who gives you no money for
alternative moments but I like his money
do you guys agree with this I think that
the giving part of Christmas is actually
beautiful isn't it also the three kings
that also gave something to be isn't it
also engraved in that tradition that was
I believe if I'm not I may be incorrect
there but it was that was after the
merging of the two traditions okay I
believe but so at the giving part I
would never criticize I think it's a
actually beautiful thing and everyone
knows how nice it is to gives and if
someone else and perhaps a present and
they're happy about what they'd gotten
but obviously there's a frenzy in like a
shopping frenzy that's been stimulated
by companies and friends and now we
recently had Halloween in Germany which
was never there and all of a sudden
people start to buy Halloween stuff and
that wasn't there before you don't like
that well I do like the tradition of
Halloween like the trick-or-treating but
it's just it feels as if you're
pressured your pressure to consume and
for if you are not aware of how much
your pressure to consume buy all of the
advertising surrounding you it might be
quite difficult to be aware of of what
you're actually doing and if you're
constantly buying things that you might
not need so when I was a little girl I
grew up in eastern Germany and I grew up
in the world and I don't know how many
actually did this by now without any
advertising just think about this for
one moment going down a street and you
have no advertising messages around you
and that is a actually was a quite
interesting I think it is now in North
Korea I mean I just saw a photo expose
from Pyongyang and the streets they're
immaculate no advertising not a lot of
cars and it does make you have a
completely different relationship with
things around you but I don't know if
that's necessarily a better way I
wouldn't rather live in North Korea than
compared to have
advertising the Wesson really but the
pressure is is there and is in its own
everyone I mean even I mean how
Christian is Christmas today I don't
think yes just it's just specific to
Christians really Christmas I come from
a Muslim Muslim background and within
our families people celebrate Christmas
you'll see the city in my hometown which
is Bradford in New York sure there's
people you know Asian families still
celebrate Christmas I think everybody
gets caught up in it because of you're
bombarded with adverse and things like
this well just just just like you saying
like on TV and things like this I I
agree with over everyone here that
giving is is good but I think I think
one of the things I was reading a
statistic that in this in the States
more than 50% spend more than they
wanted to spend meaning they get into
debt because of Christmas because
they're forced to consume their force
they see sales or they see this gotta
buy the this thing for my cousin they
gotta buy this thing for my kid and I
think if I would say anything to you
know people who are out there shopping
and you know just buy within your means
really don't get into debt also think
about the environment as well do we need
all these things you know and if you are
gonna buy something maybe look at some
of the old things that you've got and
start giving them away to charity or
something like this so you're not just
flabbergasted we just need these things
in your house that's a very it's a very
Protestant attitude that you both have
as Muslim you're very actually very
Protestant I got to say Christmas tree
ah not the moment I bet you will next
year this this this thing of not getting
into debt not spending too much I'm not
going overboard being being small and
trying to hold yourself back it's it's
you know it's part of our our our
Western culture it's part of our
Protestant culture but it isn't actually
everything it's it's it's meant to be
everything it's not actually it doesn't
make us happier to spend less or to save
more money and it doesn't help the
economy either the economy is based on
debts on personal debt and on standing
people feel better when they go into
debt and when the bill comes in January
and
no but they don't feel worse if they
don't go in today I think it's I think
it's I think it's just it's your
grandmother saying don't spend the money
you don't have
be sure to spend up don't go to the bank
don't buy that car until you have the
money on the bank to buy the car and
grandma was not an economists she wasn't
very good in it economy um
but angle America yes she and she's
she's very much like that yeah exactly
and she's a German Chancellor and also
in England they're using but it's called
austerity and that's they brought this
this Protestant tradition unfortunately
it's not working Greek Greece is still
suffering England is still suffering in
in America and Barack Obama did the
exact opposite he went into debt way
into debt and it's very slowly it is
working you could argue that that's a
that's an illusion that that that it's
it's not true it's every you can you can
argue either way but I the idea that the
idea that debt is bad and that
consumerism is bad is is something that
I don't I don't really agree with but
I'm suspicious you know we get you know
that's a different show but why does it
have to be associated with with
Christmas why do you have to have this
frenzy I mean why can't you be happy
giving your time to people you care
about and giving because we're busy shop
yeah we exactly cause we're busy
shopping I mean you know everything you
know what we're all saying here is very
nice but a good dose of common sense I
think needs to be put on the table and
people just should say I'm not gonna do
what everyone else is going to do but so
I have a fear I have a feeling that this
is like like white man Western consumer
guilt its we are who we are we're
consumers that all of us here work until
we buy and buy and buy and everything
that we do is based on buying if you I
want to watch your film I have to watch
on the internet that means I have to
have a computer or an iPad same with you
if I want to get involved and save the
world I have to do it on iPad or
something so I have to bind by and we
look at ourselves what we're doing we
realized what we're doing and then we
think is this good or bad which is good
a good question to ask but I think it's
not automatically bad we're telling
ourselves that it's bad so that we have
a feeling oh I'm I'm better than I
really am but it's not we're just
consumed by an illusion
bad and humans will always buy meaning
they will always allocate I mean we've
always done that well if we had the
power to get more grain we stored more
grain that's deep-rooted inside that you
want to allocate basically wealth you
want to allocate security meaning more
food and stuff so buying is not bad what
is bad is the way it has been done in
our world it's being done on the under
basically on the back of the planet and
of the resources so the way we consume
is basically destroying our resources
where we live and that's the problem
that's me that's a that's a story every
day but getting back to Christmas did
everyone stay in their budget for
Christmas presents this year
I don't yeah
what about you mr. bending like I've
kind of I've kind of it a developer
myself a reputation of being mr. Scrooge
and I really yes I've managed not to no
one expects to get presents from me at
all which is because you are telling us
we need to you know burn our credit
cards first of all I love the show I
love watching everyone go going crazy
and Christmas and secondly I like living
in an economy that works it works the
economy works in Germany you know this
is a rich country and that's based on
people buying exactly all right and that
takes us then to our next topic
so how can you observe the true meaning
of Christmas in this turbo thrust
commercial society well you could get
involved with a project or a group
that's dedicated to giving back to
society now that requires time and
effort or you could go online and click
your favorite petition and ho-ho-ho
you've remembered the reason for the
season well it's not that simple
perhaps it's too simple critics of
online activism say the era of click and
sign has created a class of would-be
do-gooders who don't do much at all
these days if you want to attract
attention to a cause you believe in
activism is the quickest way to get the
word out you can reach millions quickly
if the campaign has the right emotional
appeal some online activist websites
bombard subscribers with calls for
support others push you to sign online
petition
getting involved is just a click or two
away the Internet is a powerful tool for
helping activists coordinate their
actions and communicate them to the
world
but do we really always understand the
issues we sign up for critics say
clicktivism is mainly about allowing
people to feel good about themselves
while doing very little so what you're
offering is the slackers version of
doing good in society that's very
interesting way of putting it
and I disagree with you I can tell you
why so the term of selective is a
meaning to selectively but kind of being
the sofa being lazy and to be an
activist derives from a time where I
must say online a campaigning was just
in baby feed but it was just on a verge
and most petitions ranged around issues
such as stop hunger and Africa forever
stop climate change now and people would
sign but obviously no one really thought
oh my god I'm gonna making a difference
here right now and as things get better
they evolve and online campaigning now
has developed into a much much more
decentralized hyper localized version of
what it used to be so now think of
participant engagement and participation
merely being organized online by
everyone who has kind of an issue they
care about or they want to change
something so if I sign a petition to ask
my mayor to have more Street cycle how
do you say cycle lanes that is actually
something I can achieve with other
citizens together that is not something
that is far away that is climate change
this extremely complex but I can do
something within my community in my
local surroundings and that's the idea
for change a dog that providing tools
for every citizen on the planet for free
so that they can change the issues they
care about stop like going away from the
meter changing the world and wanting to
do all the better but introducing the
idea of the cell that 7 billion
solutions it's I mean it sounds good
but what it also sounds like is some
clever people will put
partitions up there and they know how to
sell they knew how to write and they'll
just wait for all these couch potatoes
that say oh that's a good idea because
you can click and send money and you
don't have to do anything and they're
gonna make a killing on people's
laziness yeah well without the any
accountability yeah well what we see on
change rhetoric is everyday people
having winning their victories with the
support of others so I mean you can have
the thesis or you can just look at the
reality and the numbers tell me give me
an example of how change.org has changed
the world in a positive way that we can
recognize so you know midwives the
profession of midwives is in danger
especially in Germany because Midwife
have to pay so high insurance to be
protected that there a minute that their
wage per hour is going down to minimum
so the profession is dying out and for
years and years and years now people
have tried to save that people have
lobbied the government to help midwives
to come up with a structure that would
make their work valuable again nothing
happened so here comes this woman she's
a mother of two both helped with
midwives her children and she starts a
petition on change.org so but you should
never forget a petition on change.org
it's not something that only takes place
online but it's an it's an issue in the
real world there's a real petition
started caring for it there's a real
decision-maker who can make a difference
and there's real people supporting her
so this woman gathered support of a
hundred and fifty thousand mothers and
fathers around Germany and they lobbied
the biggest two parties in Germany CDU
and SPD to put the saving of the
midwives profession in the coalition
treaty so change.org has actually given
content to the grand coalition that's
going that's leading Germany not change
it or change doesn't run any campaigns
it's been uncle Bastrop from the small
town of shereena Germany who has run
this campaign by her own but she
provided the forum correct we provided
the tools yes so we provide the platform
and people do their same let me give you
another example of did you make any
money though change that war to make any
money yeah we we financed ourselves
because the tools are for free for
everyone so basically I have to be paid
for my work to support future so how are
you being pay me how are you making
money so it's really easy
you come to change the work and sign a
petition let's say in human rights
issues so it might be that you then see
a small advertisement after signing a
petition or for it's a UNICEF and UNICEF
will ask you to click their sponsored
petition and if you connect to UNICEF
then and agree to for instance sign up
to the newsletter we will be getting
paid a small amount of money it's called
cost per lead acquisition okay and we
basically connect you to UNICEF or
double WF or green peas or Oxfam
thousands of organizations create that's
creating networks and you've got
organizations with deep pockets that are
paying you for doing you know the
networking well yeah deep pockets money
compared to us they have much more money
and but obviously compared to govern
governments and corporations they don't
but what's interesting here is that we
believe that online petitions or online
actions done by the citizens they can
change things but obviously you always
need incremental change you need
organizations who work on a long term
basis on issues to make sure it's not a
one-off spliff to change them
so what we do is we connect people who
are having signs that they were going to
be involved and that's 50 million now
worldwide so we're growing by 3 million
users every month it's 50 million now
it's 1.5 million in Germany and we
connect them to the organisations who
then do the longer-term involvement ok
that's the idea sounds good
is everyone feeling better I think one
of the positive things ice and how I
came across change talk was the
International labor rights forum and
warned one and this is of course you
know about garments that's why how I got
looked at and they'd after the Rana
Plaza they did a big petition to to
encourage brands to sign to the fire and
building safety agreement and I think
they go over a hundred thousand
signatories and and it did put pressure
on branch joining the fire and building
safety agreement arcadia group joined it
and so that's one of the positive things
but like you said it's not it comes from
a place post war on one and the
International labor rights forum they've
been campaigning on these types of thing
for many many years so it isn't just you
know you just click and you sign it it's
actually those guys have been doing
something about this day meeting
protesting
during rallies they've been going
outside got no idea I think when it is
being flanked is if you just sign it and
you don't do anything else that's how I
tradition you know when I should go on
protests and things you would actually
go out there you'd go on the street
you'd sign petitions and things like
that physically sign petitions I don't
think it's if you're just doing critic
say that that's what's lacking you know
yeah you it needs to be a combination of
all three things say where you actually
you take a huge interest in what you're
signing so phase the midwifery thing you
you learn more into it yeah but I think
that's what's happening here I think I
think even if you if you had the the the
hey bomber thing the Midwife audition
that's only the first action well no but
I'm thinking I'm thinking probably this
got into the papers to write obviously
you need media okay so it went to the
media and therefore media it went to the
to the to the to the politicians well
but we had that before the internet in
the 70s you would you would get someone
you have a little organization you go to
the media and the media goes the project
so it's the same thing it's the same
thing but it's much easy enough for you
and me or for people who have no access
to power whatsoever to start to create a
movement that's a problem that the
150,000 people who clicked on that
petition you know I mean it's nice but
they didn't actually do anything are
these guys you know the the the the
journalists who then who took it and
went with it those are the guys who do
something yeah I would I would strongly
disagree here because I think it's
coming it's coming together it's those
who work it's the journalists it's the
informed public and we have reactivation
rates within one campaign from 50 to 70
percent so most people never just sign
they will then have a regulation would
be they have a Facebook demo they have a
phone-in demo yeah oh yeah but what
about what about the opportunity cost of
being on change.org does this with all
this clicking at home which is nice and
comfortable does it prevent people from
going out and actually helping homeless
people you know that's the spirit of
Christmas right you should be you know
doing something that gets you out of
your comfort zone you're not doing that
when you're sitting with your laptop and
your laughs well that's easy to answer
actually so our numbers show and also
research for instance from the George
University shows that those who signed
online petitions today will be the
petition status tomorrow meaning we'll
be the ones who start and their own
campaigns those who sign online petition
are twice as likely at the traditional
counterpart donors to actually be more
engaged and taken offline action after
they're taking an online action we call
this the cycle of engagement or the
letter of engagement yes that small and
then it's about it's the art of
campaigning to pull people in and it
really we can see if you sign to ten
petitions unchanged at org the
likeliness that then you will start your
own campaign because you've gotten how
it works you've gotten how you rally for
support is increasing immensely and
that's the idea okay we're running out
of time
it is Christmas did did you all get what
you wished for yes or no I did yes I got
time with my family amazing food yeah so
yes i Scrooge yes I did I did without
giving much I did actually go but I wish
for okay and yes I did I got some nice
presents and now some nice food okay
good that's good well I did as well and
that's gonna wrap up this Christmas
edition of agenda with Brent Goff
remember you can contact me on Facebook
you can tweet me as well at Brent Goff
TV and if you want to watch the show
again go to DWS website or you can watch
us on YouTube I'm Brent Goff in Berlin
join me next time when I set the agenda
for the final time in 2013 merry
Christmas everyone